Are messy people more creative?
Are organized people boring?
As somebody who cannot find
his keys underneath his dirty
laundry, I say yes to both.
And so does science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Anthony here for D News.
And there is this
prevailing myth
that messy people are
super-creative geniuses.
Just look at the
desks and work spaces
of Albert Einstein, Roald
Dahl, or Peter Parker--
who is not real, but
feels real in my heart.
I like this theory because I'm
a little disorganized myself.
But is it true?
And what traits come along
with an organized life?
Researchers at
University of Minnesota
wanted to find out just that,
and so they ran three studies
to see how the tidiness of a
room affects human behavior.
In the first, people were
sent into either a tidy room
or a messy room and
asked to think about all
the creative ways to sell
ping-pong balls they could.
People in each room gave
the same amount of answers,
but the two independent
judges found the answers
from the messy
room more creative.
And a previous study by
Northwestern University
showed that people
in a messy room
drew more creative pictures
and could solve brain-teasers
faster.
In the second Missouri study,
the people in each room
were given menus
from a smoothie shop
and they were offered a
smoothie with a free boost.
In the tidy room,
people were more
likely to choose a boost
that was labeled "classic,"
while the people
in the messy room
were more likely to
pick one labeled "new."
So the messy room led people to
be drawn more towards novelty,
while the tiny room was drawn
more towards convention.
Boring.
Trailblazers, I tell you.
Messy trailblazers.
Anyway, the final
group was asked
to fill out a
questionnaire, and then they
were offered either a
chocolate bar or an apple.
And here's the thing.
The people in the messy
room almost always
went for chocolate,
and tidy-roomers
went for the apple.
I'm willing to admit to a
certain level of impulsiveness.
That's fine.
Oh, and also, those
people were asked
if they'd like to donate to
a charitable organization,
and the people in the clean
room donated a lot more money
and they donated more often.
OK, so maybe tidy people make
healthier, more ethical people,
but the messy people are still
the creative risk-takers,
and that counts for
something, right?
In reality, the
results just seem
to show that cleaner
environments promote safe
and conventional
behavior and messy ones
cause a break from
traditional thinking.
Those things are not good
or bad by definition.
It just depends on what
situation you're in.
You know, speaking as somebody
from the messy camp though,
it's important to remember
that in a public space,
like school or work, you have
to deal with other people's
perceptions of your habits.
57% of people in a
recent survey said
they judge people by how clean
they keep their work spaces.
And nearly half of them
said that a messy desk
is a clear sign that the
person who sits at it
is straight-up lazy.
Maybe I should
keep my desk clean
but secretly do all my
work in the storage closet.
Best of both worlds.
Do you work better in a
clean or a messy environment?
I cannot think unless I'm
surrounded by clutter.
Let me know down in the comments
and subscribe for more D News.